c'était le 7 mars 2014 l'affairé révélée
par le journal le monde
nicolas sarkozy l'ex président est
soupçonné de trafic d'influencé auprès
d'un haut magistrat débute la sphère des
écoutes un scandale d'état pour les uns
un véritable piège politique pour les
autres pour tenter d'y voir plus clair
petit retour en arrière
fin 2013 des juges place nicolas sarkozy
sur écoute
ils cherchent à savoir si la libye à
financer sa campagne présidentielle de
mais au bout du fil les juges découvre
l'existence d'une autre ligne sur celle
ci sarkozy correspond avec son avocat
thierry herzog sur une toute autre
affaire
les vues s'aperçoivent que nicolas
sarkozy et son conseil sont très bien
renseignés sur un autre dossier
l'affairé bettencourt
il découvre qu'un haut magistrat gilbert
azibert avocat général près la cour de
cassation les renseignerait en échange
de ses informations
nicolas sarkozy aurait promis d'aider ce
haut magistrat a décroché un poste
prestigieux à monaco c'est ce qu'il a
évoqué à son avocat dans un appel
c'était en février 2014 il va y avoir un
poste qui se libèrent conseil d'état
monégasque mais simplement il me dit je
sais pas demandez peut-être qu'il faudra
que j'aie un coup de pouce appelle le
aujourd'hui en disant que je m'en
occuperai parce que moi je vais à monaco
et je verrai le prince finalement
gilbert azibert n'a jamais eu le poste
après des mois d'enquêté
nicolas sarkozy et placée en garde à vue
à nanterre le 1er juillet 2014
une première pour un ancien chef de
l'état du côté de l'ump
très peu de réactions le député
christian estrosi est l'un des rares à
prendre la parole publiquement
je souhaite simplement qu'ils
bénéficient des mêmes droits que tout
citoyen et qu'il n'y aura tout
simplement aucun l'acharnement à son
enfant et nicolas sarkozy dans tout ça
dès le lendemain de sa garde à vue il
tente de se défendre à la télévision je
suis profondément choquée de ce qui
s'est passé et je ne demande aucun
privilège et si j'ai commis des fautes
j'en assumerai toutes les conséquences
je ne suis pas un homme qui fuit ses
responsabilités
le procès de l' affaire des écoutes
s'est ouvert en novembre 2020
l'ancien magistrat gilbert azibert
l'avocat thierry herzog et nicolas
sarkozy figurent parmi les coaccusés
l'ancien chef de l'état est jugé pour
corruption et trafic d'influencé
[Musique]